[Music]
on this Tuesday night the farewell to
George Floyd
I won't justice for my brother the
passion and the grief I thank God for
giving me give me my own personal
Superman and the political messages
someone said make America great again
but when has America ever been great for
a man whose desk gave life to a
worldwide movement also tonight a
reality check on police body cameras the
RCMP plans to start using them how
effective are they fears of a kovat 19
resurgence and lingering questions about
whether people without symptoms can
spread the virus Plus the Canadian
community underwater and in a state of
emergency
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the funeral for a man we'd
never heard of until 15 days ago a man
the world only learned the name of after
he died in police custody a 46 year old
black man whose name is now synonymous
with calls for racial justice
George Floyd his body in a gold casket
was laid to rest today in his hometown
of Houston Texas all of us know the name
of George Floyd out of his death has
come a movement a worldwide movement
that movement is going to change the
world hundreds came to the Houston
Church for the funeral including the
families of other black men killed in
police custody
[Music]
for more than two hours they sang they
prayed and they demanded justice
Floyd's body was then taken by
horse-drawn carriage to his final
resting place a grave in Houston next to
his mother this was not just a tragedy
it was a crime lives like George will
not matter until somebody pays the cost
for taking their lives and until we know
the price for black life is the same as
the price for white life we're gonna
keep coming back to these situations
over and over again in that eulogy the
Reverend Al Sharpton highlighted the
long history of black men killed in
America
Jackson prosecco and a service that was
both deeply personal and resoundingly
political the man whose death sparked a
national movement was celebrated in the
city where he spent most of his life
George Floyd was honored by friends and
family people who wanted the world to
know about the person they've lost thank
God give me my own personal Superman
bless y'all known as big Floyd to those
close to him he was remembered as a
gentle giant a man who would never have
expected to become a household name
those four offices were literally open
for nine minutes and then them so they
have a heart or soul this is not just
murder but a hate crime
inside the Houston Church a celebration
of life was mixed with reflection on two
weeks of national outrage we are for all
these young black men
that are coming up in this world today
and just hug them and love them because
we don't ever know when the time will
come
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden who met Floyd's family on Monday
spoke by video joining calls to address
systemic racism in America I can't turn
away we must not turn away we cannot
leave this moment thinking we can once
again turn away from racism it stings
that our very soul the mother of Eric
garner will you stand in the crowd of
mourners the families of other black
Americans killed at the hands of police
coming together in hope this moment will
finally bring about change all of these
families came to stand with this family
because they know better than anyone
else the pain they will suffer from the
loss that they have gone through George
Floyd will rest in history as a man who
inspired a national reckoning buried it
next to his mother the woman he called
out for during his final moments under
the knee of a police officer Jackson
prosto Global News will have more
moments from the funeral a little later
in the newscast here in Canada pressure
is mounting for police forces to equip
more officers with body cameras they're
already in use or a part of pilot
projects in some jurisdictions the RCMP
commissioner says it is now going to
begin the process of equipping some
Mounties with body cams
Abigail Beeman explains what difference
they could make my son was 17 years old
he was having a really bad day Riley
Fairholme was shot and killed by police
in Quebec nearly two years ago ever
since his mother has been pushing for
body cameras and I'm naive I mean look
at the color of my skin you know I mean
in the wake of all of this I think it's
important that I never thought it would
happen to me
in the wake of George Floyd's death and
more clashes between police and black
and indigenous Canadians calls echoing
Tracey wings are getting louder forces
like the Toronto Police Service and the
RCMP are supportive so is Canada's
Public Safety Minister video evidence
can provide the best possible evidence
to help inform exactly what transpired
Calgary was the first big city to roll
out cameras for all frontline officers
several smaller municipalities use them
too but there is little Canadian data
about how well they work internationally
results are mixed cameras are much more
common in the u.s. a 20-17 study out of
washington d.c noted 95 percent of
police departments either have them or
plan to adopt them but it found
body-worn cameras had no statistically
significant effects for a made in Canada
solution we really need made in Canada
data that we don't have the Canadian
Civil Liberties Association has serious
concerns about privacy critics also
point out officers can turn cameras on
and off they're also expensive as more
people call to defund police is it just
increases police budgets and it
increases forms of surveillance it
doesn't decrease the amount of policing
in our community on the amount of racism
or violent incidents of police it's not
a silver bullet
Elaine Babineaux served with the RCMP
for nearly three decades he believes
body cameras are critical for 21st
century policing combined with the right
policies and I think we've come to a
point now where you know people the
government people those in
decision-making of positions are
actually listening and that is that is
to me
watershed moment abigail Beeman Global
News Ottawa now to the pandemic in
particular the economic impact about
three million Canadians are still out of
a job or looking for work and about
eight million Canadians have received
federal help the Canada emergency
response benefit or serve today Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau says he's going
to introduce legislation to tighten the
rules on the program and could impose
fines and jail time on those who
deliberately lie on their applications
those people will simply have to pay
back the one that they shouldn't have
been taken and we're not looking at
punishing people who made honest
mistakes obviously this is a time for us
to pull together as a country the Prime
Minister says when the program was put
in place the priority was to have the
money flow rapidly that's left gaps in
the system that some are exploiting as
Michael Vittori reports the government
is under pressure to crack down on
fraudulent claims but avoid making
criminals out of people who made honest
mistakes like many Canadians Derrick
Bosh has been locked down at home since
mid-march unlike others though he can't
go back to work
even as his province is reopening
because he's undergoing cancer treatment
I'm at a severe risk for immune
infection and compromised because of the
treatment I'm in and that I should be
home for the duration of the pandemic
not just the first wave of the second
way of third wave problem is the
candidate emergency response benefit is
capped at 16 weeks which means bashas
last check will come in July he looked
at the government website to see what
other help is out there but didn't find
much the only other option that came up
with was you cannot be evicted for not
paying your rent which is not a funding
solution he's also worried that if you
reapplies for the CRB officials might
think he's trying to defraud the system
something the government is trying to
crackdown on with new legislation that
could impose fines of up to five
thousand dollars or even jail time we do
need the tools to go after those who
deliberately choose to take advantage of
people and systems vulnerability in a
time of crisis a government source says
the average rate of fraud for any
federal program at
time is between one and two percent so
with forty three and a half billion
dollars already paid out through the CRB
it's possible between 43 and 87 million
dollars may have already been claimed by
fraudsters being a minority government
the Liberals need opposition support and
so far the NDP isn't onside while the
Prime Minister took a knee one day
the same day his government was putting
in place a law that would criminalize
people who are desperate how does the
Prime Minister think that makes any
sense at all to do of course if people
made good-faith mistakes there are not
going to be a punitive consequences for
them the bloc québécois says it'll
support suit on three conditions
including that he presents an economic
update to the country by July the first
the Prime Minister hasn't ruled that out
but he says there's so much uncertainty
with the pandemic making projections
about the economy would be an exercise
in innovation and imagination Mike
lacouture global news Ottawa one of the
juggling acts parents with young kids
face is what to do with their kids if
they go back to work now in in Ontario
all licensed childcare centers will be
allowed to reopen on Friday with limits
on the number of staff and children
they'll be screening protocols in place
and increased cleaning including
removing certain toys more likely to
spread kovat 19 Ontario is still
reporting far more new cases each day
than most other provinces but there are
signs of hope there were 230 new
confirmed cases in Ontario today the
second day in a row fewer than 300 new
cases have been reported
Ontario's hospitals are able to handle
all those cases but they're now dealing
with a new influx of people people
needing treatment for other conditions
as Mike Jarrell a explains overcrowding
is as bad now as it was before the
pandemic at the height of the Cova 19
pandemic Humber River Hospital in
Toronto is one of the busiest in the
country for three months healthcare
workers were pushed to their limits look
over here
and here but today even with fewer kovat
cases
hospital yards are just as busy we had a
lot of patients that may have needed to
come in for care that we're resisting a
little bit and so we're seeing people
come in a little bit more but we are
still seeing people that have waited
perhaps too long and while those
patients are getting help doctors say
the system is once again being pushed to
its limits according to the Ontario
Health Association there were 52 hundred
patients in acute care hospital beds on
March 1st who had been treated yet had
nowhere else to go
as kovat 19 spread that number dipped
but it's now back up to pre covered 19
levels before the pandemic the problem
was due to a lack of spaces in long-term
care facilities and now those same
facilities can't take new patients until
kovat 19 is under control
leaving hospitals to pick up the slack
hospitals are terrible for people who
don't need to be there they need to get
out of the hospital setting to prevent
them from getting infections and all
sorts of other complications and
hospitals and be able to go back home
the hope is that the Ontario government
will begin easing restrictions within a
few weeks at least regionally since most
of the Cova 19 cases are in the Greater
Toronto Area McKenzie health center in
Richmond Hill for one tells Global News
it's operating at 97% capacity so a
return to normalcy will take time
elective surgeries for example had been
postponed because of the pandemic and
there's now a massive backlog that can't
be fully addressed until after fear of a
second wave of kovat 19 has passed it's
a precarious point for all of us and
that's good as we watch really those
numbers to say as we start opening
things up what are we going to see and
nobody wants to make that decision
prematurely microlight Global News
Toronto fewer restrictions means new
infections coming up the resurgence of
kovat 19 in different parts of the world
you
it's hard to believe but it was three
months ago this week the World Health
Organization declared a pandemic and
countries imposed restrictions to limit
the spread of koban 19 now as
restrictions begin to be eased there are
fears some countries such as Russia
which lifted a two-month lockdown in
Moscow today are acting too soon
nearly half a million people have
contracted koban 19 in Russia and more
than 6,000 people have died from it
Moscow where many businesses reopened
today makes up about half of the cases
and more than a thousand people are
still getting co vid 19 in the Russian
capital every day there are now more
than 7 million confirmed cases of kovat
19 worldwide as parts of the world
slowly return to some semblance of
everyday life other countries are being
gripped with big outbreaks and the
number of new cases is rising faster
than ever
Christel de Manson looks at where cases
of kovat 19 are surging and why there's
a curfew in place but even without it
there's not much to do the Iraqi capital
of Baghdad is locked down because of
copán 19 and the military is keeping
watch in neighboring Iran there's a
second wave of illness kovat 19 cases
have returned to peak levels thousands
of new infections detected after
restrictions were eased Chile is also
experiencing another spike there's
recent uptick in Poland and in Brazil
infections are climbing unabated
although the situation in Europe is
improving globally it's worsening more
than 100,000 cases have been reported on
nine of the past ten days
lockdowns can be incredibly useful in
terms of slowing down the spread of the
virus but as we've seen here in the UK
they're also harmful to the economy in
places such as Latin and Central America
which are now hotspots experts say they
just don't have the loved
to shut things down we know that Latin
America is the most inequitable region
in the world and also one of the most
urbanized regions in the world so we
have big cities like Rio Sao Paulo Lima
in where they are surrounded by belt of
poverty and inequities it's been 3
months since the virus was declared a
pandemic with continued transmission in
some locations and people regaining the
ability to move around in others there
will be waves of infection everywhere
just like these three months you know
the fact remains probably in a city like
Toronto maybe 3% maybe 5% at most of us
have been infected with this which means
there's still 95 percent of the
population who have not had it yet
that leaves all of us keeping our
distance washing our hands and paying
attention to those regionally specific
statistics so we're aware of what the
virus is doing Christel commencing
Global News London
one of the biggest unknowns is
asymptomatic transmission people who
have kovat 19 but have no symptoms
yesterday the World Health Organization
said asymptomatic transmission is very
rare that sparked a lot of pushback from
experts who say not enough is known to
be definitive about it and there's still
a risk of so-called silent spreaders
today the w-h-o backtracked saying it's
a misunderstanding to state that
asymptomatic transmission is very rare
what I didn't report yesterday was
because this is a major unknown because
there are so many unknowns around this
some groups some modeling groups have
tried to estimate what is the proportion
of asymptomatic people that may transmit
but some estimates of around 40% of
transmission may be due to asymptomatic
but those are from models and so I
didn't include that in my answer
yesterday but wanted to make sure that I
covered that the w-h-o says more study
is needed to determine how many
asymptomatic people there are and how
many might be contagious
China is rejecting some research that
claims Kovac 19 started spreading in
Wuhan as early as last August long
before
was identified at a seafood market at
the end of December the Harvard research
which has not been peer reviewed
analyzed satellite images of hospital
parking lots as well as data from
internet searches for symptoms
researchers don't know for certain if
the upward trend in hospital traffic and
search volume is directly linked to the
new coronavirus their findings may
suggest something was already
circulating in wuhan by the time the
outbreak was declared still ahead felony
in fruit how pineapple pulp led to a
record-setting drug bust
police in Poland have seized a record
amount of cocaine and they had to work
to find it investigators used axes to
hack frozen blocks of pineapple pulp to
reveal the drugs about three tons worth
it has an estimated street value of 1
billion dollars three men have been
arrested officials say the whole
originally came from Ecuador there's
some sad news about that humpback whale
it was spotted in the st. Lawrence River
near Montreal the body of the humpback
believed to be 2 to 3 years old was seen
drifting down the river today about 30
kilometers from Montreal's old port
nobody knows why the humpback made it
that far up the st. Lawrence it may have
been lost or was searching for food
Fisheries and Oceans Canada will now
perform a necropsy to determine what the
humpback died from a relentless
rainstorm is flooding southern Manitoba
leading the community of Stewart Byrne
to declare a state of emergency a
weekend storm brought up to 155
millimetres of rain to parts of Manitoba
washing out roads and drowning fields
the downpour is forecast to continue
into Wednesday near the US border crews
are scrambling to prevent more damage
there are fears the fast-moving water
might overwhelm the area's 40 year old
dykes
next the legacy of George Floyd
passionate tributes to a man who has
inspired so many to demand equality
what mourners in Houston Texas vowed
today is that laying to rest George
Floyd will not stop the movement his
death has started but the calls for
justice the calls to recognize a black
life is worth as much as a white life
will not go quiet the story won't end we
leave you tonight with more moments from
George Floyd's funeral
to what we had
I don't know if I'll ever be able to
overcome the words I can't breathe
who would have thought that his name
would now be mentioned in South Africa
Canada Nairobi Berlin South Korea Europe
a person who may not have been known by
many before I don't know where this road
is going to lead he's lucky to be
changed no more hate cries please
someone said make America great again
but when has America ever been great we
honor him today because when he took his
last breath the rest of us will now be
able to breathe I know where we've been
right now I want justice for my brother
my big brother that's big Floyd
everybody know who big Florida is now I
hope he's worth all the it's so hard
to say bye to yesterday